NHS medics are dying and dr. alpha sadhu
is one the nigerian-born retired medical
director spent his whole career in the
NHS and was also a devoted grandfather
he was working with elderly patients
just one day a week with no protective
equipment yet still managed to catch the
virus his condition deteriorated on
Sunday after two weeks of staying at
home but he resisted using up stretched
NHS resources we said goodbye to him not
knowing that that would be the last time
we'd seen and after that from Sunday
evening to Tuesday morning he just
deteriorated body shut down organ
failure I've never seen anything you
know I'm both my parents and doctors I'm
quite experienced or quite experienced
with different diseases and viruses
they're out there but I've never seen
anything like this 7 unions have called
the lack of PPE a crisis within a crisis
saying medics are being exposed to
unreasonable and unnecessary risk by the
failure to provide adequate PPE several
doctors have told us about their worries
unlike a lot of the military rhetoric
which is happening right now we are not
soldiers that are trained for war we are
ordinary human beings who have families
who have terrified for our safety and we
are terrified for their safety because
the reality is that we could be bringing
this virus home to the people that we
love most
many health workers are buying
protective equipment themselves or
getting donations amid claims that
complaints directly to the media are met
with threats and pressure to stop we've
been hearing from frontline doctors in
their droves who have concerns about
personal protective equipment about the
lack of testing of frontline staff and
as they've raised these concerns locally
they've essentially been gagged by
either managers or senior managers
within their organizations they've been
told that their social media for example
is being monitored and that if they were
to raise concerns that in some cases
their jobs and positions will become
untenable for dr. Saudis family the loss
is immeasurable and his son Danny warned
others to take the virus seriously I
remember when Boris Johnson said on the
news a few weeks ago he said you know
you prepared to lose loved ones and at
the time when he said I got really angry
I just thought you know this is not a
movie why are you saying this you know
you're overdramatizing this and I know
understand what he means I've learned
the hard way people really need to take
this seriously this is this isn't a joke
his father is viewed as a hero by many
one of an increasing number but behind
all these statistics are real people
real lives lost leaving real families
behind Alex Crawford Sky News North
London